moi je dis que des gens qu'c n'ont pas
le droit de vivre parce que nous on vit
pas on survit lui ça y est pour lui il a
payé sa dette il a été en prison et tout
mais les cicatrices qui nous restent sur
le corps toutes les douleurs qu'on a
encore aussi bien physique que que
psychologique et ben on les portera
jusqu'à notre mort nous on continue à
payer pour lui tout le mal qu'il nous a
fait un couple de tortionnaire a
organisé un un groupe de clients un
réseau de certains Distr d'autres 50
d'autres 60 clients lui il en avoura je
crois une quarantaine au procès ses
clients viennent dans les caves de son
pavillon à poigné pour torturer des
jeunes femmes qui a
[Musique]
enlevé